our exit please use either the fire exit
through the main doors of the hall or
fire exit in the storeroom adjacent to
the stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance to
the building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any longings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
live streamed today please switch off
mobiles or turn them to silent
please note that toilet and hand washing
facilities are in the foyer area
members of the public there is water for
those of you that would like to have
some refreshments
while you can of course film or take
photographs during this meeting please
note that this should be done without
disruption to the meeting and can only
be done from seats that have been
reserved for this purpose
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film this evening
and I believe there's nobody that would
like to today thank you
I will now ask officers to assist in
seeing you in the front of
what have I done so just basically yeah
right okay sorry excuse me everybody
members and members of the public please
be outstanding to receive the chairman
Reverend Kim lepley and the deputy chief
executive thank you
thank you
members our daughter first of all
let me lift this up
and soak the table
[Music]
I'd like to first of all introduce my my
chaplain the Reverend Kim lepley I'm
absolutely delighted to have her here
today for prayer and I look forward to
our year together we've known each other
a while so if you would please
it's up to you thank you
thank you all every evening whether you
like it or not they will you will be
prayed for so I'm going to begin this
meeting
um by saying a prayer for you all and
for each other so if you wouldn't mind
let us pray together
almighty God we bring before you the
meeting this evening that we who have
been entrusted with the responsibility
to govern and make decisions for those
who have elected us
that we would be guided by the best of
motives and with the interests of all
for the benefit of all
we pray Lord that you would give us
clear minds and the desire to hear all
points of view including those who may
be diametrically opposed to our own and
for an openness of debate
make us gracious and courteous to friend
and opponent alike with a real sense of
working together for this district and
the areas that are represented by each
of our councilors gathered
at the same time Lord we commend for
your blessing the work of all the
employees of Rochford District Council
who maintain Implement and make possible
the words that are debated discussed and
formed into policy
this we pray in Jesus name
amen
if you know the words and would like to
join in I invite you now to share with
me the prayer that Jesus taught us the
words of the family prayer
Our Father which art in heaven Hallowed
be thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done in earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our trespasses as we forgive them that
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil for
thine is the kingdom the power and the
glory forever and ever amen
so may God enfold you in his love fill
you with peace and Lead You In Hope and
the blessing of God Almighty the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit be with you
and all whom you love this night and
forevermore
amen
I pray for a peaceful and fruitful
meeting for you all thank you
stay for the meeting I'm afraid I have
to be a Holy Trinity
love is to be with you take
don't worry right now
[Music]
I'm all right don't worry
sorry members please see please see I
forgot
foreign
[Music]
discussing the spillage
so it's going to be a wet day
can I announce first before we do
anything those that wish to take their
jackets off please do because it's a
warm night
[Music]
we'll turn here as well
right members just a formality welcome
to this meeting at Rockford District
council's full Council members voting
will be done on a show of hands in line
with the Constitution
our law
I will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and then
and then for abstaining given as soon as
this room in the numbers of this present
please can I ask that you put your hand
up clearly high in here so it can be
easily seen by all and leave it up until
I ask you to lower it
the normal rules of debate apply no
apply no member should speak for longer
than five minutes and can I please ask
you not to repeat anything previously
said all those indicating to speak will
be given an opportunity to speak once
[Music]
right the first item is apologies for
absence
they've been received from councilor Mrs
Brewer casser sharp Council sparing and
Council award
are there any other
cash lahoy
[Music]
um councilor Knight is engaged tonight
but she's trying to make it for the
meeting so she may be late
thank you okay
thank you Mr chairman uh councilor
Carter but uh um I would also like to
add that Council award particularly
asked that the following note be noted
for the minutes and he said just to
confirm in writing I will not be able to
attend the meeting this evening due to
its unscheduled nature I would like my
apologies given and the reason noted in
the minutes being as stated above as I
had other arrangements made prior to
this change thank you Mr chairman thank
you
I would think
[Music]
members item three
um sorry item two a miniature of the
last council meeting was have been sent
out to all members I asked you
are you happy for me to sign those
minutes at the meeting held on the 23rd
of May is our group members
agreed thank you
item three to receive decorations of
Interest
[Music]
it's none okay thank you
yeah the advancements from the chairman
I.E myself for them from the lead
right
if it's not too wet I will read it
here we go I might have to jump a few
lines right
good evening neighbors right
I have the Privileges chairman in
representing this district council at
the following on Sunday the 4th of June
I attended the Holy Trinity Church
Rayleigh just to start and witness the
second Rayleigh Scouts pulling a 10-ton
lorry along the car park for a
fundraising event they did very well
it's a good job they kept the engine
running
Monday the 5th of June I attended an
open beauty and Aesthetics by Karina in
West Street Rochford and no I did not
get a manicure okay
on the same day I have my chairman
attended the grand opening Bianca's
Boutique Rayleigh Langley Riley Sunday
the 11th of June I attended the Rowley
Trinity Fair after being greeted by the
Rainy challenge
chairman councilor Daniel Belton
Danielle Belton I enjoyed the tour of
this town and its events with the deputy
Lord lieutenant
Tuesday 13th of June I attended the
Island Reserve Center Brentwood
regarding Reserve forces training a very
enlightening and friendly evening by the
Getty Curry
there's a joke to that one the same day
the vice chairman attended the Metro
Bank South in networking for the launch
of the Southern mayor's charity
Wednesday the 14th of June I attended a
Fish Pavilion south end for the
southeast as its schools Music
Association an excellent evening
impressive to see how many young pupils
can sing and display their music
Saturday the 17th of June the vice
chairman attorney Riley High Street for
the guild the guide dogs South End Flag
Day
Monday the 19th June the vice chairman
attendance and savior's church for the
mayor's South America Civic service
thank you members
[Music]
yeah that was scar off down here
oh yeah
cancel my John Mason
do you have anything to do you wish to
put forward at all in answers for the
council
no chairman I will give a report on the
work of the executive later in the
agenda thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you
all right sorry about that I've got the
hearing aid on this side not that side
right okay right so the next item I wish
to just to bring forward to is the
launch of my charity I've chosen as the
Chairman's charity an organization
called scaffed s-c-a-f-t and it's
supporting young carers and families and
and basically I learned that there are
quite a considerable number of young
people in this in this District who have
a responsibility looking after their
families and they do that before they go
to school and when they come home so you
can imagine their lifestyle is rather
limited so scaffed helped to support
this this item for the children but it's
all about the young children so some of
the things they do they support the
support children young people from 6 to
18 and their families their fortnightly
group meetings with a range of
activities they have an opportunity to
bring other children young people in
similar circumstances who understand the
challenges they raise fun and activities
outings in school holidays before they
children and they have one-to-one
support in primary and secondary schools
there's no doubt this is a very very
um
very very well organized a group and
I've spoke to him a number of times and
so that in that case I've decided to
make that as the Chairman's charity and
I hope it all goes well thank you for
that so far a lot of people have shown a
lot of support and I'm really grateful
for that
[Music]
right
gender item five minutes of executive
committee meetings held between the
period of the first of February 2023 to
the 14th of June
2023. are all those low tip members
thank you
item six
agenda item six report and a no
decisions there are none members
item seven appointment of the
representatives to outside bodies and
other forums I will invite the council's
monitoring officers Museum to introduce
these items
14 on the appointment oh okay item seven
then the appointment was representatives
to outside borders for 2023 and 2024.
[Music]
thank you chairman and good evening
members members you've probably already
heard the delightful cough that I've got
at the moment so I am hoping that my
voice will hold out this evening because
I fear you may be hearing from me rather
a lot uh during this evening's
proceedings I'm very pleased to present
this report to council which was
deferred from the annual council meeting
firstly members I would like to draw
your attention to the tabled paper in
front of you this evening which is an
updated addendum one
the conservative group leader has
notified me that his group has withdrawn
a number of nominations from bodies
where there were more nominations than
places in the spirits of collaboration
and to streamline the voting process
this evening
the updated addendum reflects those
withdrawal rules uh chairman could I
just check that all members do have a
copy of this additional paper
fantastic there Remains Two outside
organizations where there are more
nominations than places therefore
chairman with your agreement I would
like to deal with those first before we
move to the recommendations contained in
the report and members I will guide you
through this voting process because it
is going to be quite complex we're going
to take each seat in turn and there will
be multiple rounds of voting so that we
can observe Council procedure rule 12.6
which requires us to vote in rounds
eliminating the lowest uh candidate each
time and hopefully that will make sense
as we go through
the first outside body is the London
South End airport consultative committee
which is on page 7.13 of your agenda
pack there are three available places
and four councilors nominated and those
nominees are councilor JN Gooding
councilor M hoy counselor rcd Linden and
councilor s e Wootton
chairman I will be taking the voting and
rounds as set out to my in my advisory
note to all councilors which were sent
out before the annual council meeting so
accordingly we will start by voting to
the first of the available three seats
chairman if I could ask you to conduct
the vote you will need to call out each
of the names of the four nominated
councilors in turn members have one vote
each in this first round and you should
vote for the member that you wish to see
appointed to that first seat so when the
name of the council you wish to vote for
is called please raise your hand thank
you Tim
I remember we've seen so it's just a
vote for so the first one I have is the
London South End airport consultative
committee and the names come to mention
the first one I would ask you to raise
your hands if you're in favor and only
four for cancer J.N Gooding could all
those members who are in favor that
please raise their hand
thanks again yourself
[Music]
okay the next I the next individual is
counselor Michael Hoy all those in favor
[Music]
counselors only vote once
is that right so those are voted already
chairman if if I can just come in
um members you're only voting once in
this round so if you have already voted
for councilor Gooding
you don't vote again in this round
you'll have an opportunity to vote for
the other councilors if you wish to in
further rounds of voting
so do we need to go through that again
should I go through that again
I think membership in view of what it's
been said shall we read comments again
so that you all understand how you're
voting so what the what has been said is
you'll get one vote for all of these
four names is that correct so
choice is yours so if you're in favor of
a particular person vote for that person
and name nothing okay
just raise a point of order please
um as my understanding was
that we were each vote
as we wished for the four people
then the person that got the least votes
yeah dropped out
but you could vote for more than one
person
I'm sorry but I'm going to disagree with
the monitoring officer that's what I've
always understood it to be that's what
we did last year
um
so I'm sorry but I'm going to disagree
with the monitor officer
could we refer that point to the
Constitution you obviously
a chairman quite happy to respond to
that if you recall the last time we had
voting in rounds this discrepancy did
come up therefore we have been at pains
and I've interpreted the Constitution
and to comply with rule 12.6 we do need
to take it in rounds it's one vote per
round and the only way to do that where
there are multiple seats is to have
multiple votes one for each seat and
that is my determination in terms of the
correct application of of the
Constitution of course members can
disagree with me however as monitoring
officer my ruling and your application
of my ruling is final
remember
[Music]
because I'm sure
sorry Emily I've just looked at the
constitution on 416 17.6 if there are
more than two people nominated for any
position to be filled and there is not a
clear majority of votes in favor of one
person than the name of the person will
be the least number of votes will be
taken off the list
and a new vote taken the process will
con continue until there is a majority
of votes for one person so it does mean
we can all have one we all can vote for
everyone and no we've all got the votes
surely that's but it's just that what it
says in the Constitution whatever afraid
I'd like clarification please
tell me if you're happy I'll respond to
that that's exactly what the
Constitution says
um but we need to work on the principle
of one vote per councilor and the
Constitution only deals with the
situation where only one seat is being
contested so here we are applying the
rules as best we can to a situation
where there are multiple seats being
contested so I appreciate members this
isn't perfect the Constitution doesn't
deal with this uh exactly it's going to
be a job for the Constitution working
group to look at but that is my uh
interpretation of the rules chairman and
that's the way that I I intend to to run
the vote
members if you are entirely in
disability
speaking could you please wait and take
your seat please
point of order chairman
what is your point again just checking
the first person named if get what gets
the lowest vote of those that vote does
that mean that person drops out and the
other three automatically
right so we go through all the votes
voting wants in total thank you
well I think
oh it's gone off okay
thank you Mr chairman I think we've had
a lot of
discussions over this and this was well
circulated before the meeting
and I think we ought to accept the
monitoring obviously has said and get on
with the vote so I'm not sure that's
what you're going to say Mr chairman
thank you councilor um I'm going to
accept the ruling of our our officer and
we're going to continue our C so we're
going to start from the beginning we're
going to do it all again so you
understand fully you get one vote so be
careful where you you go so we'll go
back to the big
the vote is for all those in favor of
councilor Jay in Gooding
all those in favor
[Music]
okay
well the next one is for councilor
Michael hoy
[Music]
thank you very much
cancer rcd Linden
[Music]
cancer essay Wooten
foreign
[Music]
um
chairman
[Music]
um I hate to say I don't think I saw you
vote
you could be one of the abstentions
[Music]
um
because we attack the vote for councilor
Gooding because I'm not sure that the
chair's vote was counted
image we've got a a a sort of a recount
if you will uh please I'd like to ask
you again if you could show me your
hands for cancer jayn Gooding could you
raise your hands again
[Music]
um thank you chairman
um
if it's uh not too late on this occasion
could I actually withdraw my position
from this vote
which will allow then the three people
to go through
[Music]
um
we've done that then
[Music]
we've got three more
okay the members as a result of that
withdrawal we have the three members
that we're looking for
[Music]
uh please please
cancel Indus decision and you must leave
him to it so we've got the three members
um that were required for the three
seats I see no point in continue with
this
do you want me to read this out
[Music]
okay
thank you members we're going to
okay but I'd like to have noted that I
still disagree quite strongly with the
monetary's officer's advice and I would
like to take that matter up with them
outside of this meeting at a later date
very well thank you
[Music]
two
two in that one that's it really
say that one yeah
right cool then
thank you chairman um so members just
for absolute Clarity uh following
councilor Linden's withdrawal from uh
that body we now have councilor Gooding
councilor Hoy and councilor Wootton as
the three nominations for the three
places uh chair we now need to move on
to substitutes for the same outside body
so the South End airport consultative
committee and before we move to that
chair I would just like to ask group
leaders if any any group leader is
minded to withdraw the substitution
based on the result of the substantive
places and chair you did have councilor
FD indicate
potentially Hector you wish to speak
thanks chairman um don't the nominees
choose their own substitutes because
being part of their no okay fair enough
[Music]
okay
all right their members will take the
vote again with the same procedure same
rules apply and the first one is is not
these for substitutes his counselor Mrs
J.R Gooding all those in favor
[Music]
okay
next cancer councilor S.A Wilson
all right in favor
[Music]
okay thank you members
next is Council a g cross
all in favor
[Music]
okay
and the last one remembers cancer Ian
Ward
[Music]
thank you very much
members the results of their eyes
[Music]
with the airport consultancy committee
the substitutes have to be named
substitutes for the members so when you
read it out can you let us know who the
substitute is for each
member please
each member
for my chairman
I do agree with councilor stepchild on
this
we when we nominated to this body we
nominated
as a team as my understanding so my team
is me and councilor Wilson
so if the vote is in such way that one
of the lead nominees
like me doesn't have their named
substitute how does that work as
councilor steps I said it doesn't seem
to if we seem to be getting into a
rabbit hole where we're going to end up
in the wrong position
would you not need to advise yeah please
[Music]
chairman that is primarily the reason
that I read the statement out to invite
any group leaders to potentially
withdraw their substitute nomination
um that wasn't forthcoming and the
Constitution doesn't dictate that a
substitute has to be from the same
political group therefore what we will
do in this circumstance is once the
three members as substitutes are
appointed we will then allocate them and
align them to substantive members to be
that person's substitute
therefore members the results of that
voting are
they
sorry chair you haven't asked for any
abstentions
[Music]
any abstentions
and can I have that as a recorded
abstention please
[Music]
chairman the result of round one of
voting is three votes for councilor Mrs
Gooding six votes for councilor Wilson
13 votes for Council across and nine
votes for Council award
that means that councilor Mrs Gooding is
eliminated from the contest and we will
now move to round two of voting each
member will have one vote and you will
be asked to allocate that vote to either
councilor Wilson Council across or
Council award
um
[Music]
Mr chairman
um Mr chairman as there is only three
left for three places I don't see why
we're taking up the council's time by
carrying on voting for this subject
[Music]
well I'm advised that we should still
take the vote is that correct so we're
going to follow procedure I don't say
it's long windy but we're going to
follow the notes Council bill I'm really
I'm sorry because I know this has been
going on but as I understood it and
would make much more sense is the person
with the most votes goes through not the
person with the least votes drops out
what we're doing is because we've got
too many we will vote and eliminate one
and then go on to the three
that's explained right wasn't it
well we can members members we've been
abolished by our officer we're going to
follow the advice so we're going to take
the vote for those three sorry Jim can I
just ask what the purpose of this vote
is for
we if I through you to the monitoring
officer
we have three members
the one who's dropped out as you've said
there are three members we only need
three so why are we continuing I really
want to understand that otherwise I mean
I'll be abstaining otherwise
chairman if I may I will read you a
council procedural 17.6 I apologize I
said 12 earlier voting on appointments
and this is the only provision in the
Constitution for voting on appointments
if there are more than two people
nominated for any position to be filled
and there is not a clear majority of
votes in favor of one person then the
name of the person with the least number
of votes will be taken off the list and
a new vote taken the process will
continue until there is a majority of
votes for one person so that is the rule
that we are following
pivot
[Music]
okay
please thank you very much indeed Mr
chairman
um I'm reluctant to stand up and uh
introduce yet another interpretation but
my understanding is that for the three
positions there is a complete set of
voting for each position
so what actually happens is we sort it
out as I understand it the first
position and the second position is
subject to exactly the same process
again
so councilor Judy Gooding who was
eliminated in the first round then
stands again in the second round and we
go through the whole process again with
all four nominations for the three
positions that is my interpretation of
the ruling
and again I apologize but
the first the logged in there says
we're clear majority Council across had
a clear majority in the first round of
voting so it's my understanding that
he's just won that vote and we then vote
for the second seat right remember the
election members let's just clarify this
as I understand it and this is going to
be the ruling I understand what the
monitor office is saying what we did we
went for an elimination process which
we've acquired now we will vote for
those Persians into those positions they
haven't been voted in they've just been
part of an elimination process so we're
going to go through this process and do
it properly as per advised thank you
so we're going to start with the first
one the voucher game please that would
be for
cancer S.A Wilson would you please show
if you're in favor or against
[Music]
thank you very much
next was it Mrs
Mr A.G cross
already failure
[Music]
is that right
thank you members
and Council award
[Music]
foreign
just to tidy this up are there any
abstentions
[Music]
thank you members
sorry chairman through you to the Monica
officer for clarity
[Music]
regardless of what happens on the first
five second vote the proposed lead we
would have four votes
phrases on the first lot of proposals
and then moving on to this lot we then
have an additional
sorry three votes because there are
three positions
so we'd have three votes
then there'll be three votes on the next
one regardless and then the most and
then we go through it again
on that basis kind of I would
propose because I believe there are a
large number of members who did not
understand
the original vote for the original
nominees that we go through the process
again from the beginning
if you remember I was very firm when I
said we've did an elimination on the
first boat and we came we had to elect
each member on officially on the next
vote which is precisely what we did with
respect
and that's the end of it so do it done
what's the next one
chairman the result of round two were
five votes for councilor Wilson 13 votes
for Council across and eight votes for
Council award
therefore councilor Wilson is now
eliminated and the third and final round
of voting for seat one will be between
Council across and Council award thank
you
famous
shall we negative vote for
cancel the cross all those in favor
[Music]
okay and the next one councilor Ward all
those in favor
[Music]
thank you Brett members
members any of sanctions
[Music]
chairman the result of round three is 22
votes for Council across eight votes for
Council award therefore Council across
will take up the first of the substitute
seats on the outside body and we now
need to proceed to seat two of the
substitutes so this contest will be
between councilor Mrs Gooding councilor
Wilson and Council award
okay
very much we're going to try another
vote again so all those in favor of
council Mrs Gooding
[Music]
foreign
thank you members
any of sanctions
[Music]
thank you friend
foreign
the result of that vote was councilor
Mrs Gooding 14 councilor Wilson for
Council award 11 and therefore councilor
Wilson is now eliminated and we move to
the second round of voting for seat two
which will be between councilor Mrs
Gooding and Council award thank you
[Music]
members
if all those in favor of councilor
Gooding raise your hands please
[Music]
please
in case award
thank you members the next one is
Council award
[Music]
any abstention members
London stage
[Music]
determine the results if that vote was
17 votes for councilor Mrs Gooding 14
votes for Council award so councilor Mrs
Gooding takes the second substitute seat
on that body and then members we do need
to move to a final round of voting for
seat three but you'll be very pleased to
hear this will only be a single round
because there are only two councils left
in the contest and it will be between
councilor Wilson and Council award
okay man bush
right well that's your favorite
councilor Wilson
[Music]
thank you members
an audition Frankford Council award
[Music]
any absentious members
too
[Music]
chairman the result of that vote was 18
votes for councilor Wilson and 13 votes
for Council award therefore councilor
Wilson takes the third substitute seat
on that body and therefore for clarity
chairman I can confirm that councilor
Mrs Gooding councilor S.A Wilson and
Council across are the three nominations
being put forward for the substitute
seats on the London Southend airport
consultative committee
okay
right watch me
I need to pipe up again
[Music]
uh chairman we also have the same
situation for the sanctuary in Rochford
committee which is sorry sorry uh Emily
but we've got to have the named
substitutes to go with the
nominations on the committee so do who
is programmers sake Council Wootton who
is his named substitute please can we
have them that is what we've got to do
because as councilor septos has already
pointed out they must be named
substitute you can't just pick anyone
out of the three for security at the
airport it has to be a named substitute
so could we have them please
[Music]
agreement of the councilors who are
nominated for the substantive seats I
would suggest councilor Mrs Gooding
substitutes for counselor Gooding
councilor S.A Wilson substitutes for
councilor Hawaii and Council across
substitutes for councilor button for
ease all members happy with it
okay it's a new pool
chairman
um I don't think it I think it should be
done in in discussion with group leaders
and members
um
[Music]
I don't agree that it should just be I
would like to speak to council across
on this item before we agree that please
do we have to nominate number one with
their own holiday
[Music]
chairman I entirely take on board the
point that members have made around
having a name substitute particularly
for the issue around security
um what I would suggest chairman is for
the purposes of the council's
Constitution if you are able to appoint
three substantive members and three uh
substitutes we can then agree outside of
the meeting between those that are
appointed who is substituting for who so
that when those nominations go forward
to that body we have absolutely clarity
about who is the name substitute and it
will only be the person that has been
allocated as a substitute for that
substantive member uh chairman if
members are in agreement with with that
process
members are you when you agree with that
agreed thank you
how to make that
[Music]
um so chairman um unfortunately I'm
afraid that we need to do the same
process for the sanctuary in Rochford
committee which is on page
7.14 of your agenda pack and again there
are three available places and four
appointments
[Music]
Mrs Mason
thank you chair
I must say I've got mixed feelings on
this I think the monitoring officer has
been very clear both before and during
the meeting on the voting process and I
think it's a shame that it's been
questioned so much and delayed the
meeting
however
I am going to withdraw because I don't
want to this meeting to be delayed any
further so I will withdraw from the
sanctuary which gives us a straight
three for three thank you
consummation
happy with it
okay
Mr chairman uh I certainly withdrew two
of our members into in a spirit of
collaboration I would certainly like to
publicly uh commend councilor Richard
Linden and councilor Mrs Christine Mason
uh in a spirit of moving this along for
doing exactly the same thing thank you
very much indeed
I'm going I'm grateful for that said
cancel one congratulations
chairman in reciprocation and thanks to
councilor Wooten and the whole of the
conservative group thank you for your
prior withdrawals which created at least
a sense of propriety around the whole
thing and dignity thank you
thank you members
thank you chairman so again just for
clarity there are now only three
nominations to the sanctuary in Rochford
committee they are councilor LJ Newport
councilor Mrs L Shaw and councilor S.A
will say
members thank you very much for your
patience and for sticking with that
voting process now that all of the
nominations are finalized the
recommendations one to eight on pages
7.1 and 7.2 of the agenda can be voted
on as published chairman please could
you seek a proposal and a second for
those recommendations and proceed to the
vote if there are no comments or
questions thank you
you'll have a purpose of it you know I
should catch that with Mrs Mason
I'm more than happy to prepare
propose the item thank you thank you
do I have a second at Cash numbers
more than happy to Second Mr chairman
thank you
[Music]
so we'll take more than one go to it
members in this situation we've got a
number of recommendations are you happy
that we vote for them all in in one
block
all those in favor
[Music]
we're doing the vote yeah
oh sorry
[Music]
members thank you that was unanimous so
that's okay thank you
so we're near onto all Richmond cheese
[Music]
Pizza
I'm sorry
oh I'm jumping ahead right I have to
make a genderize my appointment of the
Constitution working group
I lost the monitoring officer Mrs Emily
you'll to introduce a report
[Music]
chairman I am delighted to introduce
this report which seeks the council's
approval to a to appoint a politically
representative Constitution working
group of six members and to agree the
terms of reference for the working group
are set out in the report
this working group is not subject to the
political proportionality rules
therefore I am recommending that all
political groups are allocated one seat
to ensure that every group has a voice
this will also ensure that the working
group is of a size that works in
practice given the frequency of the
meetings and consistency of attendance
that will be required
if the recommendation is approved group
leaders will be invited to appoint to
their designated place
chairman the report includes an
indicative timetable for the working
group at paragraph 3.9
I would like to emphasize that these are
long stop dates and that recommendations
from the working group and progress
updates may be brought to the full
Council earlier as necessary
members I cannot stress enough that this
will be an intensive piece of work for
the working group but the dates are
entirely achievable provided that all
members of the working group commit to
regular and by that I mean at least
monthly meetings and to completing work
outside of those meetings chairman I'm
very happy to take any questions and
would ask for a proposer and a seconder
for the recommendations I think
are there any questions canister Newport
chairman
[Music]
um I don't have any questions I would
just like to propose that we accept the
recommendations as laid out on page 8.1
recommendations one and two please thank
you
pressure machine
[Music]
thank you chair I would like to Second
councilor Newport and I'd like to take
the time to reserve to speak later
should there be a debate thank you
[Music]
chairman this isn't my uh point that I'd
want to make but I'd like to draw
members attention to recommendation two
I believe there is an error in the
numbering which I only noticed late this
afternoon because where it refers to 3.3
to 3.5 I believe that terms of reference
are actually set out
in three point
3.4
to 3.6
so I think that should be amended before
we start agreeing that we're going to
accept the recommendations as written in
the report
thank you Mr chairman
Mr chairman my apologies
um I probably had a good idea and added
another paragraph halfway through
drafting the reports if the proposal and
second are happy to um note that
correction then that's no problem
catch a new pool
yeah happy to uh accept that Amendment
okay so Mrs Mason
yes of course thank you very much is
anybody any got any questions or views
or comments no in that case then we want
to go through
oh sure I'm sorry
yeah thank you Mr chairman I've read
through the report and it says there's
no financial implications to the council
well surely there's going to be
additional officers involved within this
process for the Constitution as and when
it's working and there's no reference on
this report to actually costs and I
would like to see something brought to
this Council on what those costs would
be and what the likely cost is over the
five years because there's nothing
substantive on this and this is
something that the constitution or the
the party that's going to be set up
should be working for to let the
residents know what their additional
costs are thank you
thank you chairman in response um to
your councilor Constable's question or
observation in paragraph four uh the
financial implications
um I have noted there that there should
only be nominal costs associated uh with
the operation of the Constitution
working group so for example councilor
mileage claims or room higher should we
not be able to use a council owned a
premises but we will very much try uh to
do that that being said the Constitution
was due for review anyway therefore a
constitution working group would have
had to have met in any case and that
those costs would have been incurred in
respect of Officer time I have referred
to that in paragraph six and talked
about the resource implications
predominantly relating to Staffing
however again because that work would
have been programmed anyway it will have
a minimal impact on the officer resource
required
um chairman if I may just in respect of
any costs associated with the new
committee structure once the
Constitution working group does its work
and makes recommendations those costs
associated with any new structure will
be brought forward to the council so
that you can consider it when you are
determining which committee structure
you want to go with thank you chair
Mr chairman that was the point I was
asking that it wasn't in there is that
when the Constitution is set up and a
new committee system is working there
will be costs to this Council and to all
our residents and I would like that very
clearly laid out what those additional
costs are over that five-year period so
that we can then explain this to our
residents thank you at that point is
noted thank you
[Music]
thank you chairman um just briefly
um and the officer can correct correct
me if I'm wrong uh my understanding is
that the constitution will come before
full Council for ratification thank you
yes that's correct um question wouldn't
you wish to say something
thank you very much indeed Mr chairman I
certainly welcome the report as
irrespective of the desire to move from
a cabinet model to that of a committee
there should be a formal process to
regularly review and update various
areas of the Constitution
there are areas of our current
Constitution which are ambiguous or out
of date
updating should actually be a continuous
and evolutionary process
but I was told by a previous monitoring
officer that this was not feasible and
it would be a bespoke and expensive
piece of work to produce a new
constitution
now it seems that advice was not correct
but I'm very happy with the current
advice
did 3.2
about the political proportionality
not to disenfranchise any political
group and that is absolutely right
I would also add that I think that our
one unaligned counselor would make a
huge and very worthwhile addition to the
group but this report does not allow for
this to happen so it is a touch
contradictory in that respect
I accept that to achieve strict pro-rata
political balance the working group
would have to be a minimum of 11 as
advised by the monitoring officer which
is both desirable and workable although
I understand other figures have been
banded around and 17 was mentioned and I
certainly agree that that would be a
ridiculously large working group
but in my view the recommendation one in
its current form is far too simplistic
and it's poor practice as it does not
recognize political proportionality in
any way
and in that respect I cannot support the
recommendation as it is currently set
out albeit that I accept that the
subject needs are really dedicated and
unappropriately sized team
so I would like to make a proposal to
change the recommendation one to a more
hybrid approach
which would be more acceptable with say
one member from any group of five or
under and two from any group of over
seven
so I'm actually proposing that as an
amendment to recommendation one and that
would actually give better uh
political representation and by my
calculation would not exceed more than
nine thank you Mr chairman
I would like to second that chairman
they need
information
well lovely sure Caster saw you seconded
that Amendment yes I did thank you thank
you
so any uh
[Music]
Coastal motion do you accept that
Amendment
chairman on a point of order
um I think we go to the vote on that
Amendment yeah
speak to that
substantive
motion okay well they were accepting it
so okay
I just asked a question so
cancellation you have anything you wish
to say
on that term Amendment chairman
um my only request is that the amendment
be put thank you thank you very well
members we're going to put the amendment
to the to the members and I'm going to
ask you uh all those who to vote all
those in favor of the suggestion has put
forward by councilor wouldn't all those
in favor
foreign
[Music]
thank you members any abstentions
thank you members
[Music]
that amendment has been lost to we go
back to the original
um
cancer step tone
thank you chairman I think there's one
member of this Council that isn't part
of a party and therefore will not get a
seat on this
I would like to propose as an amendment
that that one person is offered the
opportunity of being able to draw take
part in that I think it's only very
important part because we're standing
here trying to be as Democratic as we
possibly can and what we're doing is
cutting one person out
casual Williams
oh thank you Germany I was about to
second that thank you
well you're second in the amendment
accepting the amendment of council steps
okay
Keisha Williams
[Music]
okay okay so good in you
please please could you read out the
amendment that was I didn't hear it
sorry
did you write that down
yeah
sorry repeat it chairman
that the member that is of a single
member are not part of a group
not sure why
yeah
[Music]
okay chairman that the single member
that is not part of a group he offered a
place on the
[Music]
members did you hear what was said David
no because of the noise
[Music]
chairman I'll step in and hopefully it's
only that one microphone that
unfortunately has got the feedback issue
uh councilor steptoe's proposed
amendment as seconded by councilor
Williams is that the unaligned member of
the council is also given a seat on the
Constitution working group therefore
increasing the number to seven
thank you chairman I think the the
wording was to be offered as a
[Music]
thank you
we need to ask the proposer and
secondary of the amendment whether they
want to withdraw it based on Council
taxation statement cancer Steptoe
in view of Council of Pearson's comments
do you wish to continue or withdraw that
that coming I'll withdraw that comment
okay
so in that case then um we will carry on
with the original proposal if I may
so I forgot what the original composer
was there
councilor Mrs Mason
thank you chair we do seem to be going
back to a four a bit today I agree
um
I understand Council water's concern I
don't agree with him
[Music]
um he knows that we've spoken about it
before
this process is a very important one
I have had the experience of working on
the Constitution working group I believe
at the time there were four of us and it
was almost over subscribed there it is
highly detailed work it is very
difficult to play catch-up if someone
misses a meeting it takes time
and it's
and it needs a commitment a commitment
that I am willing to give I'm all right
so I'm happy about doing it but I'm
going to do it and
the larger members would cause a problem
I think the other thing that we need to
note is that this working group although
we're drawing people from different
political backgrounds is politically
neutral the whole emphasis of the
Constitution is that it is fair that it
is balanced
that it doesn't favor size or political
persuasion and I'm sure that I can speak
for whoever else is on that committee
that the political neutrality is what
we'll be looking for and for something
that is hopefully easy to understand and
operate
so I would like
the support for this it's a very
important bit of work and whilst I
understand councilor Waters concerns I
think it would be nice to have more
consensus on this thank you
absolutely
okay interesting
[Music]
thank you chairman
um also I agree this is a very important
but for consistency and you've got a
very ambitious timetable here would it
be useful to have an amendment that's
the the six people could name a
substitute so if they have to not be
there for some reason to substitute and
catch them up on these very important
business
[Music]
chairman if I could just provide an
answer to that one uh whilst it's a very
useful suggestion unfortunately our
Constitution prohibits the appointment
of substitutes to working groups
we're going to the original version yes
are you going to read that now
so members will go to the original uh
proposals in and our officer will read
that out so you understand what we're
voting for
[Music]
accommodations recommendation are one
that the council appoints a constitution
working group of six members one from
each political group and R2 but the
terms of reference for the Constitution
working group are set out in paragraphs
3.4 to 3.6 be agreed thank you Jack
so coming from the chair then we take a
vote on this situation so
all those members who've I'm sorry could
we take both items together that's the
first thing you all agreed
[Music]
no we'd like to accept
very well we take them separately then
we'll take a section they do first part
first then the council appoints the
Constitutional working group all those
in favor
[Music]
okay
thank you very much well those against
any of sanctions
[Music]
thank you members 25 4 none against the
Knight of centuries that is carried
we go to items the second part the terms
of reference for the Constitutional
working group all those in favor
[Music]
thank you members that that was
unanimous so that is carried thank you
right we go on to item nine if we may
um
agenda itemized declaring a climate of
ecology and emergency I understand the
Council of who you have you're going to
make a comment on this
[Music]
chairman I'm presenting the report here
rather than commenting on it thank you
um
[Music]
this report sets out the rationale for
the council to declare a climate and
ecological emergency and seeks the
councilor's agreement to this
declaration
the report also outlines the council's
response to climate change
including developing its action plan to
achieve Net Zero carbon status for the
council's only state by 2030 of the
Rockford District area of our 2040.
to date 393 councils in the UK have
declared a climate emergency and tonight
we'll make it 394.
some people have asked what purpose of
carrying a climate emergency achieves
I'm happy to answer that
that now
the Declaration of a climate and
ecological emergency acknowledges that
our Council needs to act on the causes
and impacts of climate change
it shows our commitment to this one of
our administration's top priorities not
just for us but also for our residents
it allows us to follow our own declared
path to achieve carbon neutrality by
2030. which also hopefully inspires the
rest of the district to create their own
paths to carbon neutrality we pledge
them there at our support and we will
sign post businesses organizations and
residents to relevant health and
resources
there will be a dedicated committee and
smart targets to achieve our objectives
to explain this means that the targets
are a specific measurable achievable
achievable and agreed realistic and
time-bound smart the overall Target
however is to be carbon neutral by 2030
and all our great targets will be aiming
for that these targets will be hopefully
presented to the Council on the 18th of
July
resources dependent
the new committee
which would include at least one member
from all political groups and also the
non-aligned member
[Music]
will be setting the smart targets and
looking at the costs and carbon savings
Savings of new initiatives some ideas
are already being looked at such as
hydro-treated vegetable oil which
creates 95 less carbon dioxide and 25
percent less nitrous dioxide
we'd also be looking at to a pool cover
of clearance Hall which needs the
agreement of Fusion obviously at this
point in time which will pay back its
cost inside a year
through the narrowing of heating costs
and therefore the reduction in carbon
usage
um there are also opportunities
opportunities to inflate our buildings
and direct our residents to funding to
help inflate their homes these are just
initial ideas and I expect the committee
to contribute much more than this and to
build on the additional on the initial
work of the previous administration
which can be seen in this sustainability
study
um
which we would look to use to work with
and to develop
or be reporting back to each full
council meeting on the progress made
either of our origin report or verbally
and they've just formally I am proposing
the recommendations one to four on page
9.1 of this report thank you thank you
do we have a second
okay so we should put it I would like to
second that uh chairman as part
group I have invested a lot of time in
this and I fully support what council
employee is looking to achieve for our
Council thank you
of course
yeah
sorry Cass no you wish to speak
[Music]
chairman
um the report is very welcome and I
fully endorse it and I would like to put
on record my thanks to all those who've
been involved in its preparation
I'm particularly pleased that the report
has a commitment to protecting
biodiversity and enhancing the
biodiversity within the district
this commitment will be applied to all
areas of the council's work including
planning
the report highlights the ipcc report
into the increased risk of flooding due
to climate change and this is
particularly important within our
Coastal District
and it is a matter of urgency
at paragraph 2.11 the report recognizes
the role that the council plays in
leading and being a catalyst for
community-wide action and I would urge
all members to engage with their
residents and Community groups
[Music]
the report states that the council will
continue to Lobby central government for
funding and for changes to policy
I would urge that we continue to seek
grants for insulating older housing
stock and park home properties
insulation is a quick and very cost
effective way of producing energy
consumption and thus reduces carbon
emissions
the report presents the council with an
opportunity now to integrate its climate
ecological and biodiversity targets into
our new local plan and I hope we take
that into consideration
and finally a suggestion and it's not an
amendment
um but we need the widest engagement
with the community if we're if we are
able to achieve our climate goals and I
would like to suggest that the district
youth Council will be involved as they
will be affected by climate change long
after many of us have gone thank you
chairman thank you cash a step to
understand
thank you chairman I think I've cured
the feedback but
hope so uh chairman I've I'm a little
bit confused about one of two things
with this report and I have one or two
questions if I may
my confusion stems from last week's
planning committee
where
[Music]
set of solar panels was put forward to
planning which is obviously one of the
greenest themes that we can do within
our district to produce clean energy
was rejected
I find that's a little confusing
secondly I'd like to understand by
declaring a climate emergency
what other than it being a political
statement difference does that actually
make
does it open the door for other grants
that we wouldn't have been able to get
does it open the door to uh having
Consultants paid for how does that work
I don't quite understand what difference
it actually makes
with the substantial amount of work that
was already and has already been done at
Rochford District Council
also as well I would like to ask
that Essex County Council themselves are
doing a considerable amount of work on
this particular subject
and I would like to know how much of
that will be fed into
the work that RDC will be doing
members may not know
that Essex has actually the locus
Coastline in the country
corn will get a little bit upset about
that but that's the here there
and the longest part of the coastline
within Essex
is within Rochford
a good substantial part of that is
actually owned by the ministry of
Defense
so the question is how much of work will
be done in working with the mod
in taking forward particular projects
for example potten island with the ideal
site for solar panels
and various other things
so I'd like to pass those questions to
be answered before I can fully
understand what I'm voting for in
declaring an emergency it's not clear to
me Jim thank you cash a mill new sorry
to cancer or do you want to come back
before I go to cancer Mill or
thank you chairman I did mention that
some people would be skeptical I think
if someone in my originals the original
speech
um
last week's planning committee takes
place on
material planning considerations
and the planning committee decided on
material planning considerations I think
that's where we leave that the actually
declaring a climate emergency
will allow us greater
influence over our
new local plan it means that things we
put in a new local plan will have
more more grip more
substance I'm just looking at council's
step-toed smiling means distracting me
slightly and so so greater Powers if you
like within our local account we have a
climate emergency to back up
our new our local plane
the what we put in there
um why declaring
a climate emergency matters go back to
that again it it matters because we can
we're we're actually acting on it now I
think I was quite disillusioned with the
the previous
committee's work on it or working groups
work on it that it it just isn't a
working group didn't have the power to
do much hopefully this committee which
was
formed by the previous executive which
we're just moving forward with will be
able to have resources aimed at it too
help get things done it's it's not just
a question of to carrying a climate
emergency and we do nothing if through
that declaring that climate emergency
we're able to get more funding we're
able to direct residents to funding I
think in discussions with um Mr Hutton
we've spoken about schemes for
insulating park homes for instance which
are very which which do need inflated
there are there is money out there this
will allow us to investigate them access
them and direct residents to them it
allows us to to develop Reba to make
sure businesses will
get their carbon score and be able to
get advice on how to lower their carbon
output this this just leads us into
everything you could say we could do
this anyway but the issue is we weren't
and this will allow us to do it
um S6 yes I've no doubt that the Twitter
will be working with Essex I'm aware of
the climate Commissioners as you are
um mod I hadn't thought about that so
all thoughts are welcome certainly it's
something that the committee I'm sure
will consider and input from capsa
Steptoe is always welcome
[Music]
thank you chairman um I actually believe
this is one of the most vital decisions
we could make in this generation because
we need to create Focus just like all
politics are local
most pollution starts locally as well
and the government this week in the news
has saying that there's problems that
they're off track with with leadership
in this internationally but of course
they get undermined if we're not paying
attention to what we're doing locally
now this
actual effort would actually drill down
into some of the questions that
councilor steptoe's asking because
tonight's not the night for that
tonight's the night to get direction
and of course everything that we do and
everything at those hundreds of other
councils do and communities collectively
create a market for new technologies
they employ the existing ones and
there's lots of bright people out there
will definitely have ideas
and um I I'm all for this and let's take
the politics out of it and just say you
know we really need to do this I mean
this is a hot summer last year was a hot
one there's also it could be all sorts
of problems and climate is having an
emergency so really we really need to
think about that and take some proper
structured action thank you
[Music]
thank you chair
um those who know me will know that I'm
very in favor of anything green uh
you're recruit I uh I brought the um uh
fueling issue to council last year at
the the problem that I have with this
actual thing uh the recommendations that
we have here councilor Milne rightly
pointed out that we do need to do
something
but in actual fact if you read through
recommendations
there's very little action
that actually is pointed to from that
now if we're if we're declaring a
climate ecological emergency yeah fair
enough Council La Hoy says to be more
funding so why haven't we got it in the
recommendation there that as a result of
this
we are looking for more funding that
gives us a point of action
there's no point of action in the
recommendation
recommendation too is to confirm the
council's commitment well that's
confirming something we've already got
uh rename the climate and sustainable
committee to The Climate emergency
committee renaming it what does that
mean it doesn't get us anywhere the only
one that seems to have anything remotely
like a bit of action in it is
recommendation for
and I I'm all for this but the
recommendations themselves
in what we are going to be asked to vote
on
to my mind and what I read in on the
recommendations they have no substance
and that is uh something I think that we
need to work on if we're going to
actually vote on something that is
significant and worthwhile thank you
thank you okay
if I can come back um
[Music]
I think Council Aries will probably
understand the fact
that myself and the executive have
discussed this did not want to preempt
and all
group Party Committee I I don't think we
can say we will we want to be
transparent open to democracy open to
other arguments either open to other
ideas if we prescribe immediately what
these are going to be I think this is up
for the committee to decide and that's
why I said at the beginning I'm hopeful
of reporting back to the meeting on the
18th of July with actual targets
which will be initial also I did talk
about this I did give the administration
previously credit for the sustainability
strategy 22 to 30.
this may be a working Dock and it may
change over time but there are Targets
in this and this is agreed by full
Council and we
on the committee I will hope will be
working to these as well and I thank
councilor Belton I think was quite
involved in drawing this up I'm sure she
will be helping us work to that as well
so that there are things which are there
already in the sustainability study
including certain things Council leaves
is very fond of for vehicles
um
and I think we just need to wait for the
next meeting on the 18th of July and
then every report you'll get a report
from me which you might find very boring
every meeting to say how we've
progressed and what those targets are
and how we are meeting those smart
targets
yes sorry if I just made for this uh
Cash 3 pension funding and obviously the
committee would be talking about funding
as well
okay
um thank you
um thank you to councilor Hoya for
highlighting a number of the incentives
that started being investigated last
year and in some cases the years before
that and I look forward to new ideas
coming forward
um personally I Believe In Action over
words much like counselor Eaves has just
said I worked hard as part of the
previous administration with members all
around this room and offices to make
positive steps towards becoming this
Council becoming carbon neutral by 2030
and also looking at measures for
residents and businesses too some of the
ideas have been bought up today
this included the launch of rebar
updating a sustainability strategy
providing workshops for local
stakeholders calculating the RDC carbon
footprint Baseline and a lot more
all of which can be found in the climate
and sustainability service plan
my group supported many motions
cross-party and to further improve
climate change action councilor Wootton
created a portfolio for climate change
to ensure it was given attention and I
agree with councilor Hoya's point that
the working group had done some
fantastic work but didn't have the bite
to move anything forward as is often the
case with working groups which is why I
personally pushed forward to have a
climate committee set up which was
broadly supported under the last Council
the definition of emergency is a serious
unexpected and often dangerous situation
requiring immediate action
it is my opinion that to declare a
climate emergency is to imply something
has happened that we were not expecting
climate change is not unexpected and
doesn't need immediate attention it
needs constant it needs constant
attention
um excuse me counselor I mean this is
not a place for joke or laughter or
Liberty if you don't can't control
yourself please leave the whole
I don't care the excuses this is a
lawful meeting please be quiet
carry on I'm going to reiterate that
point
climate change is not unexpected and it
doesn't need immediate attention it
needs constant attention and that is why
I've personally never supported the
climate emergency label it is just a
label
I have been working in the climate
change industry for over 20 years it is
not no it is not unexpected but it does
require a constant approach to
Improvement and it's for those reasons I
do not support the climate emergency
label but I do support all actions that
are taken to combat the issue and will
work with anybody in this room to make
positive steps forward thank you
okay so Mrs Mason
[Music]
thank you chair
um before I speak generally there's a
couple of points that I would like
Clarity on
um councilor Hoy has said that he will
come to the council with a written or a
verbal report
yet in his report it says annually
um I believe he was going to alter that
and I'd like him to alter that and I do
think the report should be written not
verbal so that we can absorb the
information and get appropriate
information and ask questions if it's
verbal it's very hard to take that
information at the time so I would like
if counselor would alter that on his
report page 9.4 the report to
um for Council in writing every full
Council not just annually I believe your
intention was to do so much
right
um I agree with councilor Benson to some
extent
not surprising I guess and we also
wanted this to be a committee of full
Council unfortunately because this went
through full Council in February
we can't do so because of the six months
really it's not possible we did want a
climate committee not a climate
emergency committee I believe but we did
want that to be a full Committee of full
Council but unfortunately our hands are
tied and rather than
um not progress
this report has come forward
um I'll leave cancer high too
clarify the issue there and the other
issue is is the numbers it says nine and
I thought you said six or seven but I'm
not really worried about numbers I think
this is one committee where you need
lots of people
but what I will say
is that this new Administration it's a
joint Administration and it's very new
for this Council
we have priorities Mill Hall
Constitution change along with climate
concerns are some of the priorities of
this Administration yet this paper in my
view is fundamentally an aspirational
political document
apart from lobbying there is little
detail
I do trust that when this comes back to
Council in July hopefully in writing
that there will be a project plan with a
list of realistic priorities that we
will
see objective analysis of both the
environmental benefits and the impact on
our residents bearing in mind the cost
of living pressures that Prevail and the
exploration of funding proposals that do
not adversely impact on our council tax
revenue thank you
[Music]
I was thinking on the lines that if we
listen to what people say you could do a
collective as opposed to if you wish I'm
you know just to get
unless unless you have a specific answer
for cancer Mason
sir I said if you wish you'd do your way
okay all right council Mrs McPherson
thank you chairman
um I'd like to start by
why we should
we should I can see absolutely no reason
why we would not want to sign up to it
I'll give you some reasons
when we're talking about emergency and
it's urgent I do think it's urgent
counselor steptoe's mentioned that Essex
has the largest Coastline in the whole
of England
okay that also encompasses fairness
Island for an example
does anybody in here disagree that
climate crisis is effect affecting our
sea water levels
and then I'll remind people of what
happened in 1953
and anything we can do to revert that
sort of tragedy again we should take
emergency action
what better time to sign up to this are
we not preparing the local plan
do we want to do it next year the year
after when it's too late
[Music]
and somebody mentioned that all they see
is as a label well if it's a label I'm
quite happy to put my name against that
label and join the other 394 councils
that are sending a message to this
government and future governments that
something needs to happen thank you
yeah right we've got them in case I
wouldn't
thank you Mr chairman um
it's not a surprise to see this on the
agenda tonight as the first opportunity
for councilor Hoy to um to get the paper
forward on a subject that I know he's
extremely passionate about but just
referring back to councilor Milne he
said let's take the politics out of this
well I would actually suggest we don't
put the politics into it and um I
totally agree with councilor Reeves
because I think this is an opportunity
missed in terms of strengthening and
building on what we've actually had in
the past
I want to say that in total
clarification that
in no way would I want to diminish the
total commitment I believe that we have
in this chamber to addressing the
effects of climate change
but to take councilor eaves's point
I believe that a lot of what is in here
tonight
is worth without substance
and I believe the words emergency and
catastrophe which is what is used in the
report can be very alarming
and unsettling
and our role in local government is to
provide a sense of reassurance command
and control in what we do
most importantly as set out in 1.1 of
the paper several years ago we were
proud to be very much ahead of the issue
and gave our commitment to Rochford
District Council being carbon neutral by
2030 and district-wide 2040 and I
believe that was a total cross-party
cross-chamber view so I don't think
there is any difference in Us in terms
of our commitment and our allegiance to
doing our part uh to play our part in
addressing climate change
but I don't think words alone achieve
that I think it is about the Deeds that
we do
and I'm pleased to hear because I was
going to refer to 1.2 where we talk
about the gravity of the situation
and then we go to the next page in the
eighth bullet point under 2.12 where we
talk about a report Factor full Council
every year well that is hardly
addressing the gravity of the situation
in the cost of living crisis I as the
then leader asked for us to have monthly
reviews and feedback to Executive so I'm
delighted to hear that there has been
action to make sure that there is more
frequent lobbying back
if I turn to recommendation one and I'm
sorry to do this again tonight but if
you look at the wording of
recommendation one and this is why I
think there was haste tonight in getting
this paper here because I think it could
have been much more effective
and strength strengthened in terms of
really thinking about this
How can I
buy into a recommendation which actually
if you read the words
say that Rochford District Council is
now responsible for the climate and
economic ecological catastrophe across
the planet because it actually if you
read the words literally it actually
says that we're going to take control of
the world
well that clearly is ridiculous you know
you have to be proportionate in what we
can do
so as previously stated whilst I fully
supporting this side fully support the
sentiment
this paper as it stands at the present
adds nothing new
and adds nothing in Practical measures
to alleviate the effects of climate
change thank you very much indeed Mr
chairman members I'm going to tell you
now I've got four more members who wish
to speak they're not going to give it to
counselor Hawaii to sum up and then
we're going to take a vote
Church councilor Newport
[Music]
thank you chairman
um I'll just very I'll be very brief
because we've heard a lot about this
already
um I just wanted to come back on what
councilor Eaves was saying where
um he didn't feel that there was action
being taken in these recommendations but
recommendation two
does clearly state that we are going to
pursue efforts to achieve Net Zero CLC
emissions even earlier and protect and
enhance biodiversity so I think that
action there does speak volumes and I
think Council Hoy has really addressed
um concerns and I think he's not at all
abandoning any of the good work that's
already been done and I'm sure that this
is just going to make that work even
better and take action on what's already
been done within that work thank you
thank you councilor Mrs Wilson
thank you chair um
person I will be brief
um I don't know at the moment that if I
can support this paper uh purely because
um there is just for me just not enough
detail
um I normally support
um the green agenda as I like to call it
and for those of you that know me you
will know that I do that the problem I
have with this paper is if I had a
resident knock on my front door tomorrow
and say you're at the meeting yesterday
you you voted this through what would
Rochford district council do
at the moment all I can say is well
we're going to have a committee meeting
where we will look at proposals
for me this paper doesn't give anywhere
near enough detail I do have to say that
I support both what counselor Belton and
counselor Eve's comments are regarding
this paper and I just think it's a bit
of a missed opportunity and my ideal
would be for this paper to come back
with more detail so actually I know
exactly what I'm voting for because I do
not want this to be a missed opportunity
which I strongly feel at the moment it
is thank you
cancer generation
shop for you is it no I just forgot my
own name it's very easy to do in a long
[Music]
er
um chairman I I too am going to be as
brief as I can be we're not to repeat
previous items and previous statements
made by members particularly as they're
most likely to be agreed to
there is no doubt in my mind at all that
the fulcrum for change is the committee
the committee is the action place where
all of the true formulation of plans of
actions will take place will be costed
and they will come back to this school
council on a very regular basis not only
to be approved but also to be judged
are they successful are they not and
there will be some that aren't
and let's be fair
you can't we often tell how that's going
to roll out until you've you've tried
this is a subject this is an issue that
is consuming the whole of the world we
will look at I am sure those things that
have been successful immediately to get
the best bang for the buck best bang for
the climate buck
okay so declaring a climate emergency
that's too much for some at this point
because we already knew it
I knew it back in 1970.
I reminded myself when I read this paper
that as a student at London University I
had the amazing temerity as a as a
student of ecology to have read the
ruins and actually said to the
university I want an Eco action Society
because we need some action
I promptly got told that I made some
mistakes because I'd legal it in half
the university the really bad news was
the first thing that I was put to that I
posed to actually a climate emergency
all on my own
but joking aside students accepted that
was the med the method we only had of
communicating apart from notice boards
and in the bar and of course I didn't go
to the bar much
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna support it
I'm gonna support it because
climate emergency has become a shock to
many many millions of people across the
world it's been denied for decades
and at last people are now accepting the
science and there is such a thing as
climate change and all the adverse
effects that we see
so for those who have been shocked I
want to shock you some more I want to
shock you with it's an emergency we
recognize as a council it's an emergency
and we are going to do some more
we've started it and that's how we will
go on
I'm going to support it
I'm going to support it provided the
committee comes back with real things
and real real events and real real
savings and things we see for our
residents that actually work thank you
chairman thank you and last but least
Council Foster
thank you chairman
I'll try to avoid repeating some of the
things that had been said
um some are ironic to be considering the
Declaration of a climate climate
emergency at this point
they can reflect on a couple of
decisions that have been made in the
past and then I'll put them into context
later on
not very much
um first of all in February the then
opposition voted against solar panels on
the roof of a social club
even though the application was
completely compliant with RDC policy on
panels in Conservation Area
[Music]
last week only last week
the planning committee voted against the
solar farm off the a127 as we all know
Western really location very accessible
for development without big disruptions
Rayleigh Town Center
low-grade arable land that after the
installation of a solar farm could be
used sheep grazing and also for
biodiversity enhancements as I said I'm
going to get to the relevance of this in
a moment
an argument was put forward to use
Brownfield sites for cyber generation
RDC already has a policy that uses
Brownfield and contaminated sites
contributing toward our housing
commitment importantly the policy
already includes the requirement for new
homes to generate power
it is in itself though however not
enough in contributing towards
delivering carbon neutrality
it's true to say that there are no easy
solutions
but the refusal of The Proposal last
week was in my view a bad decision
solar panels are a great opportunity but
the attitude towards them last week
seemed to be
a great idea but not here
a green opportunity wasted
I get to the point of my earlier
references now only this week
the planning directorate the planning
inspectorate announced its decision on
an appeal against the decision by
Hamilton
Council in North Yorkshire to reject a
solo sorry chairman on a point of order
is it wise for us to be discussing a
planning application which went through
last week and as the chairman of the
development committee said may go to
appeal
um May I make my complete making my
party chairman
for information I can give you the
appeal reference if you wish the
description of the application is very
similar in size and geographical context
the one rejected by the problem on the
point of order I'm sure the members
should be speaking to the paper not to a
planning application from last week uh
yes I am chairman but I'm putting some
context ahead of it
in the context of wasted opportunities
who's talking
who's who have spoken for about one
minute and 30 seconds it's not there
sorry remember but some I could hear
people talking and I'm I am not going to
have it because I should just close it
down so if you've got something to say
you put your hand up and you address me
otherwise be quiet I don't care who it
is carry on
so that application was very similar in
size and geographical context to the one
rejected by RDC last week inspector
allowed the appeal and granted planning
permission
the appeal decision is well worth
reading it provides electricity for
approximately eleven thousand homes
similar to the rally one it even talks
about the fact that resting the land
from agriculture would probably improve
soil quality the applicant has applied
for and been awarded full costs against
the council
RDC has a policy of Net Zero by 2030
that plans to get that Target were
delivered by the working group were led
by councilor Joe McPherson
the question is bearing in mind the two
decisions I've just mentioned apart from
grabbing a headline what does declaring
a climate emergency deliver how will it
improve our plan there are no answers in
the paper in declaring a climate
emergency what is the cost there are no
details
so I reiterate some of the points made
I would just like in closing to
refer back to my criticism of the solar
decision I'm not anti-trees
um in the early 1990s as chairman of
Hawker Parish Council I personally led
to campaign to acquire a park we planted
three thousand uh whips which are now 3
000 mature trees my point is
if we have to lose trees in certain
situations there are compensating
factors that can well take care of them
kind of catch the Foster can I get back
to it though we're really talking about
uh the the uh suggestion of declaring an
economic change I understand what you're
saying and I'm sure a lot of people have
sympathy for that but can you really get
back to the end of the forest finish it
strikes me sir that the um the
Declaration of a
climate emergency is a headline but not
as described in the paper not an action
thank you now I know there's many people
who still wish to feed but I think we've
spoken about this long enough and I'm
going to invite uh
casual Ahoy or or alternative to sum up
so that we can get into a you because
you've got a choice you vote for it or
you vote against it cancel forward you
wish to sum up
thank you I think um some of the
councilors deserve an answer to their
questions first of all I think
going back a while
[Music]
um there is a it seems that people are
still asking about what does this do
I think if you look at the report on pay
page 9.4
just above three financial implications
you'll see the first footage point above
that is to measure our progress using
Council climate scorecards that in
itself is a way we're going to measure
ourselves it might surprise some people
here to know that we score three percent
on that at the moment I think some of
the work the previous administration
does it might be a little bit higher now
and the way the scoring may make us a
little bit higher but it's three percent
we can we will be measuring ourselves
using that
regarding
Castle Foster's point about how does the
effect planning we've said the point
above that ensure that all Council
decisions budgets and approaches
to planning decisions are in line with
the shift to net actually says net Aero
but it please means Net Zero and that's
the type I was going to pull out
carbon emissions by 2030.
as I keep saying
there will be a plan
for this I felt in this
when we were not part of the
administration we kept saying
let us in
why don't you talk to us more why don't
you listen committee is more what do you
live share things more
it would be remiss of us
not to listen to what the conservatives
want to say or other bodies want to say
we need to listen to them before we set
targets I don't want to impose my
thoughts on this Council I think it
should be a whole Council coming forward
with our targets I'm happy to take
responsibility for them and if I fail
I'm happy to take ownership of the
failure
but the com the committee
needs to set these targets so the
committee is familiar with them and can
own them as well and that's where I'll
leave it
[Music]
I'm still getting indication but I'm
gonna have to call it we're running out
of time for the rest of the agenda so
we've got a proposition we've got a
second note so what I'm looking at now
is we've got a full
recommendations and I think under the
circumstance if you take them separately
so
under you've got them before you to
declare private change so starting from
I'm going to take the vote so from
styrofoam I I'm sorry Mr chairman as a
point of order we've asked for
clarification on the dates the verbal
report given by councilor Hoy conflicts
with the written report and I'd like
that clarified by councilor Hoy before
we go to the vote okay so can you just
verify apologies council Mrs Mason I I
did take that on board and I've ticked
it and said the report will be to every
four council meeting it'll probably
report it will report to the executive
as well before those Council meetings
and I'm happy for it to be a written
report
very well thank you so we'll go to item
one then to declare climate ecological
emergency and Technology
[Music]
a request a name to vote please chairman
a named bow yes
[Music]
thank you thank you
but the benefit of the the people of the
debate we need a fifth and that we've
got that so we've we've recorded for it
okay there's a recorded vote so we're
going to go for item one to declare
climate ecology ecological emergency
acknowledging that the council needs to
prevent a climate an economic a logical
ecological catastrophe all those in
favor
[Music]
yes oh yeah oh sorry I'll do it I'm
jumping the gun
man Sean you will read The Knowing down
so I do apologize
I'm just getting excited
at this one it's hard on one just one we
could do each one individually
[Music]
brilliant
so uh I'm asking you to vote on
recommendation one members
um
when I call your name can you please
indicate if you wish to vote for against
or abstain
councilor Mrs Belton Epstein
[Music]
councilor Booth abstain
councilor Mrs butcher abstain
counselor constable
against
cancer Crips
councilor Cross Four
cancer FD four
[Music]
councilor Eaves abstain
councilor Foster abstain
cancer Mrs Gadsden abstain
councilor Mr Gooding
councilor Mr Gooding oh four
[Music]
councilor Mrs Gooding
councilor Hoy before
councilor Lamborn
councilor Norman or
[Music]
councilor Linden or
councilor Mrs Mason
counselor Elliot Mason
councilor John Mason
[Music]
councilor Mrs McPherson for
councilor Milne four
councilor Myers
for
councilor Mr Newport
cancer Lisa Newport
[Music]
councilor Mrs page for
handsome Mrs Shaw
abstain
[Music]
council Mrs Squires Coleman
Council Stanley or
henceless Steptoe
councilor Williams
for
cancer Mr Wilson
Mrs Wilson
cancer Wharton abstain
[Music]
for a tree
then there's the results for that are 24
one against and 12 web stains therefore
that is carried we now take item two to
confirm the council's commitment to
achieving Net Zero carbon status by 2030
for its own estate and by 2040 for the
Rochford District area and pursue
efforts to achieve Net Zero CO2
emissions even earlier earlier and
protect the enhanced biodiversity
we'll again take the recorded vote
[Music]
okay so chairman I don't think anyone
called for a recorded vote for the other
recommendations
actually that's true because we would
like to do anything that is actually
true so thank you for that counselor
um I appreciate that so in the view of
that and we have an outdate request I'm
going to ask therefore that we take a
vote on um on item two
we've had we've had the proposes of
secretaries and we so they'll ask them
all those four
[Music]
you know she's she's just putting up
yeah okay thank you members
were those against
[Music]
any abstentions
too
[Music]
zero against thank you man Bush the
result there is 31 4 0 abstain against
and two abstentions therefore that is
carried
we're now taking item three tonight
rename the kilometer and sustain its
sustainability committee to The Climate
emergency committee
although all those in favor
[Music]
any against
abstentions
[Music]
members
22 4
against and nine abstentions therefore
that is carried we come to item four the
council Lobby that the council Lobby for
further funding and policy changes on a
national level to support the delivery
of the sustainability strategy all those
in favor
[Music]
thank you
okay
[Music]
memberships unanimous therefore that is
carried
[Music]
members go to item 10 business from the
last meeting does any member have any
business
uh from the council meeting held on the
15th of February
none thank you
March 11.
a generalized military report from the
executive and committees to council
members there are none
item 12.
item 12 a report from the leader of the
work of the executive councilor John
Mason I believe that senior
hence thank you chairman it's a bit of a
shame not to use the facilities as they
say when you check out of a hotel but
maybe as we're getting so close to 10
o'clock and you're going to need the
popcorn for this one maybe
um I ought to just try it from here and
see where we go now I start to fall a
bit I'll cruise over to the lectern
okay good evening members good evening
officers
um this is my first opportunity to give
feedback and share with full Council the
work of the executive Under The Joint
Administration
my report is verbal this time but I will
ask for the minutes to include all the
main points that I'm sharing with you
now and I'll pass this note to Sonia so
she can achieve that
we circulated all members on the 2nd of
June the roles and responsibilities of
each lead member
with Lauren stretch having taken up her
appointment as director of housing on
Monday welcome if she's here I don't
know no but I still welcome her and um
by that situation all lead members are
now engaged directly with service
directors
you have debated tonight
and voted on proposals to take forward
work on a new Constitution and committee
system of governance for the
2024-25 municipal year
as a heads up I can tell you that the
working group will also be asked to
consider bringing back the area
committees but on a new model of direct
engagement with residents
you have also agreed
tonight to declare a climate emergency
and the climate emergency committee will
meet in July in order to consider
formulating actions and plans both
internal and external to the council and
bringing these to full Council on each
month
the appointment of an RDC Duty manager
and staff to manage Mill Hall is
underway
and there will be a deed of variation
to the Leisure contract approved by RDC
to withdraw Fusion from the managing of
leisure operations at Mill Hall
direct engagement is being renewed with
potential Partners who responded to the
eoi very very shortly and options for a
new operating model will be brought
forward by officers to an executive
workshop on the 19th of July
the executive workshop will also receive
options for consideration
leading to a review of the ADP and
alongside that we will also look at
options for Castle Hall
at the same time
we will be reviewing funding sources and
the capital program to allow for
proposals to come forward to full
Council
there will be opportunity for all
members of the council to be briefed as
necessary ahead of any paper and any
recommendations to full Council
the planning policy committee will meet
on the 27th of July and with a program
of regular committee meetings members
will be asked to approve and work to a
critical path timeline plan of many
steps and deliverables leading to a
recommendation to council for a
preferred options consultation as soon
as possible
but do keep your Diaries free towards
the end of the year
in view of the delay experienced in
setting an earlier date for the planning
policy committee the lead member will be
issuing a briefing note update to all
members
we have reserved the all member briefing
in September for a presentation and
debate on Devolution and greater ethics
but we're in the hands of the
negotiators and the government to reach
an agreement of course
CCTV
this project is under review
it is being given priority
food waste
a revised plan has been recommended by
the service director
and delivery by RDC and Norse or rather
JV is expected to be in early Q2 20224.
and finally and certainly not least the
it discover the I.T recovery Disaster
Recovery plan and test log is being
reviewed
thank you chairman I look forward to the
next opportunity to bring forward and
report to you on the work of the
executive thank you
members win here come
to council
thank you Mr chairman
um I would like to ask the leader as we
have now set up two committees would the
makeup of those committees I.E which
members are going to be on it brought to
members as a matter of urgency so that
if any member has anything they wish to
bring to the committee's attention they
have that availability please
confirmation
chairman all I can say is the lead
members will do that thank you thank you
okay we now move on to item 14 uh sorry
13 public questions and questions on
note is members there are none
item 14 motions I noticed there are none
so therefore that concludes the business
visit of this meeting and the time now
is 9 4 47 and I close this meeting
[Music]
so there
[Laughter]
[Music]
which bit yeah
okay
members of the public can you please
make your way out of the hall with us
thank you
thank you okay ready
please be upstanding why the chairman
and deputy chief executive retire from
the meeting thank you
thank you
um
members of the public can you please
make your way out of the hall without
delay can I please ask you not to
approach any of the counselors if you
wish to speak to anyone can you please
do so out in the public foyer thank you
all for attending this evening
foreign